- So, first up, we have Michael B. Jordan,
in the boxing movie, Creed.
- You know he's great, a great performer,
great actor, great looking guy,
my only question is, is he too young?
- Exactly,
I mean are we really gonna give
such a grand achievement to somebody
with such a modest body of work?
- Oscar should go to someone
who's been tested, you know?
Someone who's seasoned.
Someone who's--
- Jennifer Lawrence.
- [All] Yes.
- Yes yes yes.
- I mean you look at her, and you think.
Warmth, talent, safety.
- Something that I
didn't feel from Jordan.
- Especially safety.
- Yeah.
- My thoughts exactly.
- So I think we're all in agreement,
Jennifer Lawrence for best actress?
- Yes, absolutely.
- Moving right along, we have uh,
Straight Out Of Comp-ton,
for best picture,
am I saying that right? Comp-ton?
- Wow, just an awe inspiring body of work.
- I remember sitting there
in the theater thinking that,
but, you know, it also
fell a little short for me.
I just couldn't connect.
Something just, it just
wasn't believable enough.
- You know, I agree.
I mean the point of a film like this
is to convey the poetry of a journey.
- Well, if we're talking about journeys,
we may as well mention
Matt Daemon's journey.
From Mars?
- Yes.
- Mars is so far!
(giggling)
- I mean you drive from Comp-ton
to Hollywood a couple
times in an afternoon,
but try going from Comp-ton
to Mars more than once?
- Can you imagine how many
potatoes you would need for that?
(laughter)
That entire film just portrayed
such a harsh environment,
where the average person
would have fallen victim,
but he was able to overcome.
- Yes.
- You know Matt Daemon seems like
someone you could just grab a beer with,
you know, like a friend, or a colleague.
- Or a husband.
- Well, I think we're all in agreement,
that we're nominating The
Martian for best picture.
- Yes.
- Okay, let's see, what else.
Oh, of course.
Beast of No Nation, actor Abraham, Atta?
For the best leading role.
- You know I loved him in The Wire,
but this time around he just felt...
A little bit...
Incorrect.
- Yeah.
- I love these chocolate chip cookies,
but something just tastes
a little off about them.
- They're too chocolatey right?
- Too chocolatey.
- I try to eat around the chocolate chips.
Pretend they're not even there.